hi there today we're looking at learning
world graphs to accelerate hierarchical
reinforcement learning by when Ling
Xiang at all from Salesforce research
this work is based in the world of
reinforcement learning and especially
hierarchical reinforcement learning so
in hierarchical reinforcement learning
the idea is that in order to perform a
task like in this case they perform all
of their experiments on mazes like this
so imagine you have this maze and this
red thing here is the agent and the goal
is the Green Square and the gray things
obviously are walls and the black things
are everywhere the agent can move the
agent can always move one step any in
any direction that it wants and that
isn't blocked by a wall so in order to
fulfill such a task the agent needs to
take many many steps like go here here
here here here here each one of those is
a step in addition this specific maze
has an additional property namely that
there's a lock to door here and first
you need to pick up the key to basically
to open the lock the door so in order to
reach the goal the agent needs first to
pick up the key then open the door then
go to the go and each one of these it
has to traverse many many steps so the
idea in hierarchical reinforcement
learning is that you have two parts to
it to the agent so your agent which is
this entire box here is divided into
what's called a manager sure and a
worker and this is a divide so what the
manager sees the manager sees basically
it I do an example here they do it
differently but the manager could see
large could see the world basically only
in these large chunks right and it
doesn't really care what
is in or it cares what is in the chunks
but it doesn't distinguish points within
the chunks it just knows about these
these chunks basically and what the
manager will say Oh first I need to go
to this chunk here then because there's
the key in this chunk and then I need to
go to this chunk here because there is
the door and then I need to go to this
chunk here because there's the goal so
the in the view of the manager which has
a very high-level view of the world is
the the action sequence is down here
over here then over here
those are like three actions that's a
pretty simple and then the manager would
pass this information to the worker and
it would say hey worker please go to
this state here please go to the first
state and then the worker would be
tasked with basically moving the
individual steps to go not to the final
goal but only to go to that chunk and
then in that chunk the worker would go
to the key and then once it has the key
the manager would say good job now
please perform the second action which
is go to to this chunk here
so the second action that the worker
would so you basically get the idea
whoops I am doing something here you get
the idea that the I'm creating text
boxes that the worker and the manager
work together in that the manager has a
high-level view of the world and then
the worker can basically execute the
actual actions that the manager has
decided on in a fine-grained
way so this is gives you several
advantages namely the manager can plan
high-level and far away things and then
the worker really only has to care about
its close neighborhood because each step
the manager proposes is a fairly short
range so the worker can implement it
they do this in a kind of different way
so let's actually start from the back
from of this paper which is I find is a
bit more explanatory and it makes a bit
more sense to look at it what they
propose is to learn a world graph so in
a world graph what is a world graph a
world graph consists of of two things
first a set of states which is the or
the blue states here so all these blue
states which are so-called pivot states
or important states so these are states
in the world that are very important
determined by some measure right so
these are basically states that look at
look at where they are they're often
that like narrow passes you see here
here they're at these narrow passes so
basically if you if you reach those
states as an intermediary goal then you
can basically go a lot of places from
here so these are very let's say
powerful states and these states are
connected by a neighborhood graph so
basically which states of these are
close to each other and for example here
you would connect of course those two
because they're neighbors those you
would probably connect those some I'm
attempting to to kind of draw the world
graph you can you might connect those
doesn't need to be like a tree it can be
like such so you see that the the graph
kind of takes shape these are fairly
reachable
so whenever a node in the graph whenever
one of these important states is fairly
easily reachable by some other state
it's designated as a neighbor so with
that with this world graph here this is
what you get you get an abstraction
basically you get a set of states with
connections between them that says how
easy or hard is it to reach from one
state to the other if you have these
things then you can really
easily imagine a hierarchical
reinforcement learning algorithm that
now in incorporates this information
namely the manager will only use the
important states to plan so for example
if the goal the goal isn't drawn in here
but let's say the goal is here and then
the door the door is here it's a locked
door here and then the key let's draw in
the key come on
okay this doesn't want to all right
think the key is somewhere let's say
here there's the key here is this all
right then the now let's put the key
further away
come on so over here I'm gone off with
the colors and key here all right so
what would the the manager do the
manager would then say ah okay the key
is here so this would be a good state to
reach of my importance if the manager is
only allowed to Co important states
right so the manager says because it has
the graph right it says aha this state
is easily reachable from let's say this
state and this state is easily reachable
from this state so it plans go here and
go here and then go here then get the
key right this is a kind of a micro
action that is not an important state
then I need to you know go here this is
reachable from this state that's
reachable from this state and from this
state and that's reachable from my
origin so from the key then next go here
go here go here go here and then open
the door and then of course go here and
solve the the task the worker then would
only ever need to implement the
following it starts here
and it says aha I need to go here what
do I need to do I need to go for example
down and over and now once I've done
this I need to go here so I need to go
right down right so you see the the
worker only ever has to care about going
from one hop to the next hop making it
really easy for the worker while the
manager only has these blue states
available which makes its search space
much more much more condensed and much
more much more over viewable especially
with the nodes in between the world
graph so that's if you have the world
graph right if you have this set of
states and how important are how easily
they reachable reachable they are
between each other you can very easily
do a reinforcement learning approach
that that is a hierarchical has the
manager plan on the world graph has and
then has the worker implement the
fine-grained actions and there is
already a method that does this this
paper here uses feudal networks so we
won't go into that later just saying
it's pretty easy if you have those
things so the real question is how do
they learn the world graph and what they
do is the following then they describe
it here in kind of this oh sorry this
way what they want to are to finally
learn is a prior that tells them for a
given state how important it is it and
that's a beta prior a beta distribution
is a continuous approximation on a on a
kind of a binary 0 1 variable so how do
they do it they use an LS TM to encode
trajectories so these are trajectories
from kind of rollouts of policy and then
the the lsdm encodes it and for each
step it outputs
this posterior over the what's called
these latent variables here they say how
important is a state so these are the
posteriors whereas this over here is the
prior and the posterior of course only
makes sense in context of a trajectory
that's why the ultimate decision happens
for the prior because the state needs to
be important or not important to any
trajectory so what they do is they roll
out policies and they have certain
methods of of doing this so they have
they have random exploration of
curiosity goals but they also train this
continuously so they updated
continuously via this what's called a
goal condition policy and what a goal
condition policy is basically is you put
the agent somewhere in the maze actually
let's use this maze over here you put
the agent somewhere in the maze let's
say here you for example make a bunch of
rain make a random exploration that's
here so you know these two things are
reachable and then you train they'd and
say go from here to here right this is
your goal now the agent tries to kind of
reconstruct this random walk to there
and you can riff so so this is how you
train an agent to basically go from any
- well reachable States to each other
right from here to here and so on now
you won't train it to go directly from
here to over here because a random walk
would be very hard for around the walk
to find its way over there but what you
end up with is is somehow an agent that
is able to reach closeby States and
that's exactly what the worker is
supposed to do right here and so all of
these trajectories you can then unroll
them and decide on the kind of on these
on these pivotal States
so how do you do that and this is where
this top part here comes in so down here
you input the trajectory and you output
how important is each state all right
and now you see in this example here the
light color means that the lsdm decides
this state isn't important and the
darker orange color means the Alice team
decides this state is important so what
you do next is the states where it
decides it is important that notice the
beginning at the end are always
important
it feeds to a second LS TM as an input
you see here here here so in this case
of these four of these six states in the
trajectory three are important namely
the start the end and this one here
where the lsdm decides hey that's
important that goes into a second LS TM
which is generator so this here is an
encoder and this here is a decoder and
what it does is it decodes the sequence
of actions right and here given nothing
just given this it decodes a sequence of
actions and at the end what you want is
that the actions output here reconstruct
the actions input this might sound a
little confusing but the core value of
this is what you want is to reconstruct
the actions of the trajectory taken
given only the important states what
does this mean in our example in our
example here this means if I have to go
from here to here right and for example
I took the following path this is this
so right right down down right this is
these were marking sequence now if I
only have the start the end and one
state in between let's say this one all
right then can i reconstruct what
actions were
taken and if I erase the blue thing and
I tell you I went from here via here to
here then you could very much
reconstruct the actions here so this
state here is a good candidate for being
an important state whereas if if it were
a different state if it were for example
if I told you I went from over here to
here and then to here you'd say well
this could be either something like this
or it could be a path like this right
there could be many many paths or like
this could be many paths leading from
earlier so this state here is not
probably not very important so that's
kind of how they how they learn which
one are the important States via this
encoding trajectories in an LS TM and
trying to reconstruct the state the
actions taken in the trajectory given
only the states that were deemed
important by the lsdm so that's how you
train the lsdm to recognize important
states and once you've recognized the
important states in a trajectory you can
then use those to learn prior so
basically you ask over all possible
trajectories which of the states are
generally important and that's how you
end up with these blue states all right
and then the last part is to connect the
blue states and that is fairly easily
done in their approach what they say is
all right
we have blue states which would be pick
one and we do a random walk from it
right random walk random walk random
walk if we hit another blue state like
this one here in the random walk we
simply say well there are probably
neighbors so we do this a bunch of times
if you hit the blue States of course
without hitting another blue state first
then you connect the two in the graph so
these would be connected these were
probably connected what we ended up
at the beginning right you have this
graph maybe these two are connected and
so on so this gives you this world graph
and now you end up with a set of
important states and connections between
them that tell you which ones are easily
reachable from each other so you can
train the manager on that you can train
the worker as we said before to simply
select two closeby States trainee to go
from one to the other that by the worker
will alert that so
in essence that's how they they do it
you can look at the experiments
themselves they show that this basically
transfers so if you terrain like this
pre train then you can give more
specific and more complicated tasks and
this will this will rapidly accelerate
the learning of this yeah look at the
experiments if you have time that was it
for me thank you for listening